so what is capitalism capitalism
fundamentally is a series of
marketplaces you could have a
marketplace for lemonade a marketplace
for lemons a marketplace for trucks to
transport lemons a marketplace that
fuels those trucks marketplaces that
sell wood to build lemonade stands
however capitalism of course as we know
is this either celebrated term or
condemned term it's either revered or
it's reviled and I'm here to argue that
this is because capitalism in the modern
iteration is largely misunderstood in my
view capitalism should not be thought of
as an ideology but instead should be
thought of as an operating system think
of your iPhone your iPhone merges
hardware with software apps and hardware
now think about all the hardware as the
physical reality all around you and
think of the apps as entrepreneurial
activity creative energy and in between
you have an operating system as you have
advances in hardware you have advances
in software and the operating system
needs to keep up it needs to be patched
it needs to be updated it new releases
have to happen and all of these things
have to happen symbiotically the
operating system needs to keep getting
more and more advanced to keep up with
innovation and this is why fundamentally
when you think about it as an operating
system it devolves the language of
ideology away from what traditional
defenders of capitalism think but even
if you go to the Constitution you'll
notice before the founders even got to
the First Amendment with free speech
free religion Free Press they thought
about patents and copyright they talked
about the government's role in promoting
Arts and Sciences it's the reason why I
could not start a search engine tomorrow
called goggle
Google doesn't own G's but I couldn't do
it because there could be some confusion
so even property rights have ambiguity
built into that and on and on and by
1900 you have other types of property
that come into being for instance
imagine that in 1900 you owned a hundred
acres of land someplace in the Midwest
it's very easy to see where your fence
ends your neighbor's property begins now
let me ask you where in the sky does
your property end does it end at
thousand feet five thousand feet ten
thousand feet it makes no difference
because other than the novelty of a few
hot-air balloons
man couldn't fly but within three years
he could now all of a sudden it was very
much relevant whether your land ends at
a thousand feet in the sky five thousand
feet ten thousand feet and you have to
have someone arbitrate that and indeed
that's exactly what happened in five or
ten years from now when Amazon wants to
deliver a package over your house to
your neighbor from that UPS truck we're
gonna have to decide does your property
end at five feet ten feet 50 feet
hundred feet where does it end and there
is no ideology that'll tell you where
your property ends it's an operating
system and similarly we're gonna see
this with automobiles few years after
the Wright brothers figured out flight
human beings started using more and more
cars and all of a sudden the regulatory
system the operating system had to be
patched to all of a sudden addressed the
safety of consumers that the consumers
of vehicles were presenting danger to
horses other pedestrians trolleys
what-have-you and all of a sudden the
driver of these automobiles had to have
driver's licenses eye exams registered
Motor Vehicles speed limits rules of the
road so that horses pedestrians could
coexist with cars
it had to be backwards compatible so a
new invention had to basically fit
advances from the past
similarly five or ten years from now
we're gonna see the same thing with
self-driving cars coexisting with human
driven cars the reason why this is
important is in ten years
another thing is going to happen beyond
drones and self-driving cars but you're
going to see the most valuable economy
in the world the
largest economy in the world is going to
be a country run by communists the
Chinese seem to be very good at
capitalism and this is going to have
fundamental problems and present an
identity crisis for the United States
because for a long time free markets
coincided with liberties such as free
speech free press free religion and all
of a sudden this equation is going to be
decoupled and when it gets decoupled we
might find the democracy the multitude
of voices actually impedes capitalism
because a state that does not have any
pretense of limited government can very
quickly mandate a regulatory framework
for drones for electric cars for
self-driving cars for any new innovation
where they feel that they can leapfrog
Western societies and this is a very
unique thing in the American experience
and this is why it's very important to
think of American capitalism as an
operating system and not as an ideology
because when you think about it as an
ideology you can have good politics make
for very very bad policy that market
outcomes and democratic voices and
battles for votes can end up stifling
progress so over the next few years as
this political cycle plays out you're
going to see American democracy rise to
meet the challenges that capitalism
poses and modernity poses and I ask
policymakers to think about decoupling
ideology from economics and think about
how good policy can ultimately become
good politics thank you
[Applause]